it was a an act really of wanton cruelty
committed against defenseless television
viewers last night CNN subjected its
tiny audience to what it described as a
climate change town-hall the thing went
on for seven hours that's a long time in
fact that's so long that climate
predictions made at the start of the
evening could have been proven wrong by
the end an entire species of polar bear
might have become extinct by the third
commercial break it's a long time and
yet in the name of science a few hardy
souls attempted to watch the entire
thing now we can't say with certainty
what happened to them though of course
they're in our prayers but at least one
of them lapsed into total
unconsciousness watch this say enough of
having the oil industry the fossil fuel
industry right all our laws in this area
and over he was the lucky one if he was
sleeping deeply enough he might have
missed scene on asking Julian Castro
what his administration would do to
fight quote environmental racism we're
not making that up but that's just the
tip of the rapidly melting iceberg
though it was billed as a show about the
environment in fact last night was
really an exercise in sweaty moral
posturing at times the evening became so
strident that even the candidates on
stage couldn't keep up with it all Cory
Booker for example he tried to reassure
viewers that Democrats don't really want
to take people's meat away apparently
he'd forgotten that Camel Harris had
just called for that I hear about it all
the time Booker wants to take away your
hamburger well that is the kind of Lies
and fear-mongering that they spread out
there that somehow the Democrats want to
get rid of hamburgers
but what you support changing the
dietary guidelines yes you know the food
people yes yes a reduced red meat
specifically yes I would so Kelly Harris
been thinking a lot about what you eat
and she thinks you eat too much red meat
and she plans to do something about it
once she's elected god that and a number
of other things in fact there are quite
a few things in America that Kamla
Harris
plans to ban immediately will you commit
to implementing a federal ban on
fracking your first day in office
adding the United States the list of
countries who have banned this
devastating practice there's no question
I'm in favor of banning fracking yeah
so would you ban on offshore drilling
yes and I've again worked on that laws
are a big thing right now
yeah do you ban plastic straws I think
we should yes banning drinking straws I
mean mindless and annoying if you
actually cared about plastic pollution
and you shouldn't care about plastic
pollution because it's horrifying
you would punish China for dumping
plastics into the ocean but of course no
one on the Left wants to do that because
they're busy sucking up to China but
banning fracking now that's just
demented our energy sector is the single
most successful part of the entire
American economy it's one of the only
things propping up our trade balance
right now it's been a savior of last
resort for rural areas devastated by
globalization
Kamla Harris doesn't care about any of
that she probably doesn't even know when
you're a soulless demagogue bent on
acquiring power at all cost
details are not relevant all you see is
yourself at the finish line arms in the
air ambition is a powerful drug and yet
if we're being honest about it Harris
was not even close to the least
appealing candidate on the stage last
night that award goes without question
to father Pete Buddha judge the patron
saint of South Bend Indiana Father
Buddha judge launched into a sermon last
night that would have made Jonathan
Edwards proud sinners in the hands of an
angry climate God you know if you
believe that God is watching as poison
is being belched into the air of
creation and people are being harmed by
a country
are at risk of vanishing in low-lying
areas we suppose god thinks of that I
bet he thinks it's messed up at least
one way of talking about this is that
it's a kind of sin you shudder to think
of the torments waiting for you and
father Pizza Pisgah peléan version of
hell imagine him lecturing you
superciliously for eternity wagging his
little fingers in your face bragging
about his virtue it's enough to make you
want to obey father Pete though fears no
such judgment at the very same time he's
yelling at you about belching poison
into the air of creation father Pete
himself is likely to be sipping Perrier
at 50,000 feet in the least a Gulf
Stream according to an Associated Press
report Buddha judge flies on climate
destroying private jets more than any
other Democratic candidate in the race
right now how could that be we asked the
butt of Judge campaign that question
today and they responded here's their
response quote we fly commercial as
often as possible and only fly
non-commercial when the schedule
dictates non-commercial oh that makes
sense the schedule dictates so when it's
convenient father but a judge follows
his own Commandments the rest of the
time when the schedule dictates he's
happy to belch poison into the air of
creation so you're not allowed to drink
from a plastic straw that's immoral
but father Pete gets to keep his private
plane so no wonder rich people love
climate activism for them it's all
upside it's not so great for everyone
else unfortunately for poor people in
the third world it's gonna be especially
tough they're not gonna be allowed to
have as many children as they would like
watch Bernie Sanders explain empowering
women and educating everyone on the need
to curb population growth seems a
reasonable campaign to enact would you
be courageous enough to discuss this
issue and make it a key feature of a
plan to address climate catastrophe well
the answer is yes and the answer has
everything to do with the fact that
women in the United States of America by
the way have a right to control their
own bodies
the precision and the Mexico City
agreement which denies American aid to
those organizations around the world
that are that allow women to have
abortions or even get involved in birth
control to me is totally absurd oh there
you go
Sanders says it right out loud the
Africans are having too many babies
we're gonna have to make sure those
Africans have more importance we're
gonna pay for African abortions we're
also by their we're gonna have to
control what people eat how they travel
and where what they do for a living
we're gonna have to control every detail
of their formerly personal lives we're
in charge now of everything that's the
message